[Musique]
pour ce faire les enfants ou sur les
autres os avez vous été sage au 12 août
au sol est-ce que nounours ça a été ça
jusque vous font rien pour trop gros
qu'aucun de nounours va vite voir pas
prenez les nicolas au lieu de faire le
perroquet occupe au trou no joyeuse mais
ne veille pas trop tard tout bonnement
comme pour vous
[Musique]
oh
comme nous mettons d'accord répond pas à
la maif motivé aux jeunes locaux de
prendre la recette facile tu veux voir
trois gardes ouvrent des grands yeux je
parle
là
je le cache quelque part
pendant que tous les deux vous fermez
les yeux et quand je dis ça y est vous
cherchez miné et anti froid quand on se
bat et choquant on trouve près de
copenhague
allons-y c'est moi qui te six mois ferme
et les utilités nous aussi nous allons
jouer avec eux nous allons faire très
attention et essayer de trouver le livre
là-haut pimprenelle va le cacher les
pêches j'aurais dû prendre monde au
japon mais pas mais s'il ya bien caché
je vais me lever
[Musique]
c'est plus chaud c'était c'est chaud
vous les trouverez pas preneur je le
trouvais non c'est bon d'accord patron
nous l'avons vu longtemps à trouver un
sens c'est vrai alors le robot cemac ils
cassent à l'esam et les yeux bon bon bon
[Musique]
jeu 15 regardez il ne vient que ce matin
bonfi du colloque tu johnny gros avait
bien caché
[Musique]
yannick olland va se coucher ou
j'ai eu vent en sa le marchand de sable
va être bien qu'on gère 1 49 bien sûr
les enfants apprenaient à demain petit
ami nous jouerons encore souvent avec
vous si vous êtes aussi gentil que
pimprenelle et nicolas
à peu voilà nounours allons en route
bonnut des enfants fait de duren à
demain abo
oh
[Musique]
e
[Rires]
[Musique]